there is no elation in our family today  following this sentencing  our amazing husband and father has been  taken from us in an appalling and  violent manner  nothing will ever compensate for that  we will wake each day  and immediately feel our loss  we will struggle through each day for  the rest of our lives  our last thought before sleep will be of  david  we will forever shed tears for the man  we have lost  we shall never get over this tragedy  it breaks our heart to know that our  husband and father would have greeted  the murderer with a smile of friendship  and would have been anxious to help  how sickening to think what happened  next  it is beyond evil